at some point you can collapse the
division between self a personal stuff
and world generator again and a lot of
people get there by a meditation or some
of them get their via psychedelics some
of them by accident and you suddenly
notice that you are not actually a
person but you are a vessel that can
create a person
and the person is still there You
observe that personal self But You
observe the personal self from the
outside
and you notice it's a representation and
you might also notice that the word that
is being created is a representation if
not then you might experience that I am
the Universe I am the thing that is
creating everything and of course what
you're creating is not quantum mechanics
and the physical Universe what you're
creating is this game engine that is
updating the world and you're creating
your valence your feelings your and all
the people inside of that world
including the person that you identify
with yourself and as well are you
creating the game engine or are you
noticing the game engine
um you noticed how you're generating the
game engine
and I mean when you are dreaming at
night you can uh if you lose have a
lucid dream you can learn how to do this
deliberately and in principle you can
also do it during the day and the reason
why we don't get to do this from the
beginning and why we don't have agency
of our feelings right away is because we
would game it before they have the
necessary amount of wisdom to uh to deal
with creating this dream that we are in
you know you don't want to get access to
cheat codes too quickly otherwise you
won't enjoy so stage five is already
pretty rare and Stage six is even more
rare you post to basically find this
mostly this Advanced Buddhist meditators
and so on that uh dropping into this
stage and can induce it at will and
spend time in it so stage five acquires
a good therapist stage six requires a
good uh Buddhist
spiritual leader it is for instance
could be that is the right thing to do
but it's not that these stages give you
scores or levels that you need to
advance to it's not that the next stage
is better you live your life in in the
motto it works best at any given moment
and when your mind decides that you
should have a different configuration
then it's building that configuration
and for many people they stay happily at
stage three and experiences themselves
as part of groups and there's nothing
wrong with this and for some people this
doesn't work and they're forced to build
more agency over their rational beliefs
than this and construct their Norms
rationally and so they go to this level
and Stage seven is something that is
more or less hypothetical that would be
the stage in which it's basically a
transhuman stage in which you understand
how you work and which the Mind fully
realizes how it's implemented and can
also in principle enter different modes
in which it could be implemented and
that's the stage that as as far as I
understand is not open to people yet
oh but it is possible to the process of
Technology yes and who knows if they're
biological agents that are working at
different time skills than us that
basically become aware of the way in
which they are implemented on ecosystems
and can change that implementation and
have agency over how they're implemented
in the world